bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation comment est ce que vous
vous qualifiez cette élection
présidentielle au togo faure gnassingbé
qui brigue un quatrième mandat est un
monde est finalement qui vient à la
croisée d'un processus à la fois
diplomatique politique et économique y
est relativement favorable au togo c'est
à dire que nous avons un président qui
effectivement est arrivée au pouvoir des
conditions qui sont peut être de notre
point de vue un peu lointaine et moins
démocratique mais qui a réussi depuis à
stabiliser un pays à lui donner un
contexte de paix les élections se
déroulent dans un contexte extrêmement
pacifier le deuxième point c'est un axe
diplomatique c'est un pays qui est
coincé finalement entre des voisins qui
sont pour certains entre compliqué le
burkina faso c'est un point qui est
comme le nigeria ou s'il a réussi
finalement à trouver un équilibre de
relations dans cet espace là et puis
surtout sur plan diplomatique à
l'international c'est quelqu'un qui a
réussi à se poser à la croisée des
grandes puissances des grands blocs de
puissance que sur l'union européenne
partenaire historique la russie très
fortement avec un prochain forum je
crois qu'il va se dérouler au togo et
puis les états unis et la chine donc c
c'est tout ça se traduit par un contexte
économique qui est même salué par la
banque mondiale aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que c'est un pays extrêmement
l'informateur le premier depuis depuis
deux 2 enquête de la banque mondiale qui
est le plus réformateur d'afrique ce qui
est quand même un relatif explorer qui
pour le coup elle c'est bien ce qu'on a
entendu depuis la population doit
maintenant traduire ces données
macroéconomiques pour quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus dans le quotidien des
gens et ça c'est un point qui doit être
l'enjeu du prochain tas de celui qui est
quand même le favori de cette élection
est l'enjeu de l'alternance démocratique
il ya quand même deux poids lourds de
l'opposition qui sont en lice dans cette
élection agbéyomé kodjo et puis jean
pierre fabre
l'opposition justement qui dénonce une
mascarade nouvelle mascarade électorale
droitos elle est assez dans le contexte
de la région dans le contexte du
continent africain c'est une élection
qui est qui bourg où le groupe permet à
défaut aux autres forces politiques on
n'est pas dans une élection qui
effectivement organisé contrôlé par un
pouvoir il ya débat il ya des opérations
électorales tout à fait normal il ya eu
des campagnes tout à fait ouverts pour
le coup on voit bien d'ailleurs la
cuisse ans et l'organisation d'ailleurs
des forces d'opposition comme celle
d'ailleurs du tenant du titre si je puis
dire
donc on est dans un contexte encore une
fois j'insiste est reçue qui a fait
campagne dans la paix et c'est un
événement majeur un bourrin pays qui
étaient largement historiquement découpé
entre le nord et le sud avec des enjeux
de voisinage qui était compliqué je
crois que ça c'est un élément de
réussite
là vous avez raison c'est que healy a
parfois des critiques il ya parfois des
éléments comme partout si vous voulez
aujourd'hui le contexte électoral soit
le continent africain où ailleurs dans
d'autres zones et et parfois chahuté et
parfois un petit peu pour être largement
améliorée évidemment mais et c'est un
des enjeux en plus de cette idée de que
la macro économie extrêmement réussie
puis ça l'est encore davantage sur le
terrain la vie quotidienne des gens
c'est aussi finalement de poursuivre
l'ouverture politique d'ouverture
politique de ce pays au sens interne et
de continuer ce que fait le président
aujourd'hui
la sib est de maintenir de manière dans
un équilibre de relations diplomatiques
et je crois que c'est dangereux là
évidemment pour la population est
essentielle l'opposition a raison sur un
simple de deux points de critiquer
notamment encore une fois des éléments
qui a maintes fois se ressemble à notre
pays dans le voisinage bien ailleurs sur
notre blé mail mais c'est un élément
majeur que de dire que ça se déroule
dans la paix la paix électorale est un
point essentiel pour que les élections
se déroulent normalement
et pourtant ligne à obtint
non pas qu'il n'y a pas de
représentation de l'opposition au sein
du parlement comment est ce qu'on peut
parler dans ce contexte là d'ouverture
démocratique
c'est un point qui doit se faire
effectivement là vous pointez du doigt
les mois extrêmement important c'est un
élément qui encore une fois est dans une
grande rencontre démocratique et s'est
fait progressivement cette élection et
participe encore une fois de l'ouverture
je pense que la prochaine étape c'est ce
que je disais tout cas je vais peut-être
pas dit suffisamment clairement ses
textes un point qui doit encore une fois
être affirmé notamment au niveau
législatif et au niveau était prochaines
élections qui seront celles les
élections encore une fois qu'ils nous
servent le parlement lui-même et je
crois qu'on a last un point ou sur
lesquels les différents candidats
devraient se rencontrer notamment à
partir du prochain combat et qui
permettra encore une fois dans un
contexte qui si on le compare à ce qui
se passe autour d'eux de ce pays est
évidemment à faire progresser mais qui
est largement exemplaires sur différents
points de vue maintenant maintenant
prochaine étape effectivement c'est
l'une des sélections par la question qui
concerne la mission d'observation
l'union européenne qu'est-ce qui est
absente pour ce scrutin alors qu'elle
avait toujours quasiment étaient
présentes on se souvient des élections
de 2010 où le avait d'ailleurs salué
l'élection de faure gnassingbé
alors je crois que c'est laid c'est
aussi la traduction concrète de quelque
chose qui se passe dans la diplomatie du
pays
je pense qu'il y a on l'a vu récemment
avec notamment des points de contacts
plus que des points de contact
d'ailleurs des des engagements qui sont
liés avec notamment la russie mais aussi
de manière plus distantes avec les
etats-unis mais aussi avec la chine joue
à kaya rééquilibrage des relations ce
qu'il peut parfois aussi posé des
difficultés mais c'est aussi un défi
pour l'union européenne que de saisir
des opportunités ou en tout cas la
capacité renouvelée de cette diplomatie
qui ont encore une fois fait face à
aujourd'hui une compétition avec
différents blocs l'union européenne fait
face à la russie fait face à la chine et
les états unis dans le cadre d'un
contexte encore une fois d'un continent
africain qui s'est largement ouvert à
autre chose que la relation par exemple
la france avait avec ces pays là merci
beaucoup jean christophe aguessy
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
relations internationales docteur en
sciences politiques et enseignant à
l'université de paris sorbonne mercian